[Applause]
hey everyone I'm a Strawson and may the
4th be with you as in January 4th it's
not much anyway like it or not the Star
Wars conversation is still revolving
around the last Jedi and full
transparency I loved it i'ma show
whatever the last Jedi answered a lot of
questions but also raised some more yeah
this is that dangerous game of
speculation because anything we say here
could be completely 180 don us in
episode 9 but here's what I'm wondering
my unanswered questions when it comes to
the last Jedi question one well Luke
come back as the force goes I don't know
for sure but it seems like the original
plan was to have Mark Hamill's role as
Luke Skywalker finish with that
beautiful moment on Crete slash octo and
be done beautiful binary sunset I could
talk about it for hours
Lucas ol president Kathleen Kennedy had
previously said that episode 9 would
have been Carrie Fisher's movie and with
her passing there are no human legacy
characters left for episode 9 Lando
where's Lando so the question is will
they bring Luke back as a force ghost I
think they will even if it's just for a
small moment I do think they need that
that legacy character at least for
episode 9 but I also like I just said I
think this would be a good opportunity
to bring back Lando where is Lando what
is he doing
what has he been up to I mean he blew up
the second Death Star let's not just
credit Lando had a big role in taking
down the Empire at least temporarily
where's Lando question - how will a
bisoder 9 handle Leia blast Jedi ended
with Leia and the small portion of
what's left of the resistance as always
with hope but it did leave us with a
huge question what will happen would lay
at the start of episode 9 Carrie Fisher
did not film anything for episode 9 but
her story to me was essentially wrapped
up I mean she really handed over the
reins to Poe her apprentice this is
actually gonna lead me in right into the
next question because I'm gonna talk
more about this but will episode 9 have
a time jump this is something that
Germaine was here hey Jermaine and I
talked about in a previous video that
you can check out on this page
that came right after the last Jedi came
out and he speculated that the movie
could start with the time jump maybe
five ten years down the line and open
with Leia's funeral which i think is a
good idea and circling back to something
i kind of mentioned will Poe lead the
resistance I think the combination of
we're layin post story web versus Carrie
Fisher's unfortunate passing I do think
that Poe will be a leader in the
resistance or if not be leader of the
resistance like I said there's not that
many and he was lays a Prentiss she
taught him a lot a lesson she reeled in
that you know flyboy attitude that got a
lot of people killed gonna have to deal
with that do you think I mean what are
the repercussions of you know treason
and sending a lot of people to their
death I mean I love you but people kill
next question will we see more of tamiri
black if you're wondering who I'm
talking about
to Mary Black is brown kid broom kid has
a name I don't know if I'm saying this
right because it was revealed in the
visual dictionary his name but it was
never actually spoken in the movie if
they do go at the time jump I think
Jermaine said this too we could have
this older to Mary black to Marie black
or maybe he'll show up in a TV show or
his own comic or a novel or maybe he was
just a symbol of hope that there are
more Jedi out there this brings me to
the most divisive question of this video
who were raised parents oh boy okay so
the current conversation on the world
wide web is that kylo Ren may have been
lying to ray about her parents or may
have planted the idea that her parents
are nobody into her mind via the force
or maybe Snoke did it
or maybe kylo did it to get her to join
him to make her think that she's not a
part of something when she actually is a
part of something huge uh to me this
question was answered
she said it he said it I don't think it
was a misdirect could it be maybe but to
me she said it I don't think that
they're trying to trick us
I really think her parents are no one
sorry but is Captain phasma actually
dead
yes here's a question I
genuinely really want to know the answer
to where is Luke's green lightsaber we
saw Luke using it when he went to kill
kylo Ren spoilers but that was a
flashback and then when Rey meets him he
doesn't appear to have it
he never uses it did he throw it into
the sea cuz we know he's like he's done
with the Jedi and then he threw the blue
one over like did he do that same thing
with the green one daybreak it was it in
the tree
did ray find it and keep it like she did
with the Jedi texts where's that green
where's that green baby speaking of
which what will Rey do with the Jedi
techs by the way Rae did have the Jedi
text that Luke thought burned up she
took it with her on the Falcon well ray
start training a new generation of Jedi
via the text well she trained boom kid
to Mary Black next question what
happened to the Knights of Ren what's up
with the Knights and red we have kylo
but what happened to the other guys dick
I'll kill him what's up with that some
of the force awakens
who are the Knights of Ren will we find
out anything else about Snoke you know
this build up to this all-powerful
leader and then you just kill him it's
so great well but when we find out more
I don't really care if we don't I feel
like I get it but I wouldn't mind a
novel about him I don't even like a
whole thing in episode 9 but are we
gonna find out more about him don't know
but let's talk about ships for a second
and I don't mean like the Millennium
Falcon I mean relationships well rose
and Finn's relationship continued our Po
and Rey into each other look say what
you will about romance and Star Wars I
definitely think there's a place for it
and I love it and Rose totally kissed
Finn is that gonna continue but see you
into it too and also her Po and Rey like
into each other you see that chemistry
there he was like I know who you are
babe
anyway one last ship I really want to
talk about though Maz Kanata hooked up
with Justin Theroux code breaker was
Justin Theroux
can we talk about she hooked up with
Justin Theroux I love it those are all
the questions that I have pertaining to
the last Jedi might unanswered questions
that I hope are addressed in episode 9
are there any that you are wondering how
do you feel about this Rey parentage
thing do you think it was answered
divisive conversations let us know in
the comments below or you can always
tweet me I'm at ash cross and available
to talk star wars pretty much 24/7 i
tweets so much literally oh my god thank
you guys so much for watching let me
know what you want to see next week fair
when we doing farewell